hello everyone I really am wondering if
any of you have ever seen this game as I
find the game pretty amazing and I don't
know it's kind of weird that no no
channel on YouTube decided to show this
game as well this was the candidates
tournament in 1985 and the purpose of
this tournament was to determine the
challengers of the winner of the match
as part of Karpov and well it's played
between the ante man who is a well-known
Grandmaster and the Canadian Grandmaster
Kevin's bracket and well I've never
actually heard of Kevin's bracket but he
is the fourth Canadian to ever win the
title of Grandmaster and he is the only
Canadian Grandmaster to ever compete in
the candidates tournament so although Mr
Kevin's brag at one last place and this
tournament he actually played a
brilliant game against TNT man who
finished fourth in this tournament so
let's see this game it's it's quite a
fascinating game I mean a piece
sacrifice in this game is like like none
other
it's it's not a sacrifice you know to
attack your opponent or anything like
that it's just a weird positional
sacrifice but it's it's quite pleasing
so mystery on teaming has the white
pieces and the Kevin's bracket has the
black pieces we have d 4e 6 C 4 and we
have Bishop to b4 with check this is the
carers defense by the great Paul Karras
we have Bishop to b2 and now Queen to e7
and mr. sprocket says that he plays
their Queen to e7 following the analysis
of poker as himself and the Paul says
that this is a great move but later it
was determined that it's really not but
nevertheless this bracket follows this
so we have e 4 and now again sprocket
plays a move suggested by Paul Kerr as
he plays d5 and this gentleman replies
Eve 5 and here's bracket says that well
he doesn't really like his position now
as he doesn't really understand how to
attack White's Center he says that c5
isn't really good after Bishop captures
on b4 and f6 isn't really really
something to hope for with black as he
doesn't really see him catch
F captures on e5 so here after every
after some thinking mr. Sprague at sun's
his inner nimzowitsch and plays Knight
to c6 as he decides to attack the pawn
center with his pieces we have Knight to
f3 by teaming and Bishop captures indeed
to queen capture 72 and now D captures
on c4
we have Knight to c3 by teaming and the
knight to h6 we have d5 and well this d5
is isn't really the best move as as mr.
sprocket says a yanti man totally
disregarded i moved at mr. sprocket can
play here as Kevin plays Knight captures
on e5 and what kind of a move is this I
mean obviously it's a piece sacrifice
but but why we have Knight captures on
e5 and now he captures on d5 and okay
this opens up the attack from the Queen
and this night the knight is pinned so
obviously black will win the piece back
at some point by playing f6 but we have
Queen TV - no defending the knight and
the well now if six isn't really doing
anything and gentiemen is threatening
Knight captures on d5 so how do you win
the pace back well the thing is you
don't as mr. sprager plays Bishop to e6
he doesn't he doesn't mind this being
down a piece in a position like this
yanti man castles Queen side and we have
c6 here and what's the idea well the
idea is that this Queen had to go to e2
to protect this knight on e5 and now
she's blocking this bishops path into
the game and also by blocking the bishop
he's also blocking his rook on h1 from
coming into the game so until white
figures out how to get his pieces into
the game it's really not like black is
down a piece so this is actually
actually a brilliant idea
we have a knight back to f3 and now
castle Knights to d4 and we have rook a
to e8 now well both the rook and the
Queen are on this Queen I need to we
have
g3 preparing to play Bishop to G - but
now b5 and this is
well this is a this is a very powerful
pawn storm after I've every five joins
in we have nine chapters on e6f captures
on e6 and f4 and here well this is a
very interesting idea as blacks black
black is still down a piece he plays Eve
five and here we have F captures on e5
and tonight to f7 going for that he five
pawn but now as the white is up a piece
he plays east six
he doesn't mind giving up this pawn and
we have Queen captures on e6 black even
trades Queens being down a piece so
Queen captures on e6 rook captures on e6
and well in this position of white does
want to develop his pieces a playing
Bishop to g2 doesn't really it doesn't
really promise that much as this pawn on
d5 isn't really going anywhere and on
Bishop to Bishop to h3 rook to h6 is
undermining the bishop so what tries
Knight to e2 going for that d4 square
attacking the rook and the c6 pawn we
have rook to e3 and now King to be one
we have Knight to e5 preparing to go to
d3 with the night so we have Knight to
f4 now the bishop is protecting d3 and
we have g5 kicking that night away from
f4 we have 9 to e6 with an attack on
this rock on f8 rope to f5 and here
night to d4 now attacking again this
rock on f5 rope to f2 and we have G 4
and timin gets an idea that he would
really like to give up this pawn because
after Knight capture Sun g4 rock to g1
and what white is getting back into the
game after age 5 and h3 what white is
okay here this is well black but white
is still up a piece but blacks pawns are
pretty strong so this would probably be
something like a draw but after g4
a mr. sprager plays rook to e4 now
attacking and now attacking this pawn
with the rook so team on defense this
would H 3 and we have B for the pawns
are going forward
Knight the seat
and we have a five defending the B for
porn and here the ante man was in a
serious time trouble and well probably a
move like I don't know B three or maybe
maybe maybe even H for trying to trying
to get his rook into the game would have
been better but he played a three and
well we have B three here and the team
on wasn't really afraid of this as he
thought he had this move Knight to d4
although here you don't really want to
play nice to a one that's just the silly
place to put your night or maybe in
nights the e1 yeah oh you always want to
go forward with your pieces so we have
Knights to d4 and well here this was
actually that this was actually a huge
blunder and mr. Kevin's bracket punishes
this well he really punishes it and I
will invite you to define the move that
punishes this Knights to d4 idea so I
will give it a couple of seconds if you
want to pause the video and find the
move for yourselves okay well for those
of you who found the move
congratulations it's it's quite quite an
interesting move and for those of you
who just want to see the move
mr. Kevin's bracket played rugby too and
in this position mr. young teaming
resigned the game as there is nothing
for him to do here the idea is after
rook captures rook simply rook to e1
check and the king has nowhere to go
White has to block this roof to d1 and
rook captures and e1 is checkmate
so after rook to d2 white could try
something like Bishop to e2 but this
simply loses a piece with rook captures
night and although white isn't down a
piece because he was up a piece for the
entire game but black is up three points
white can't hold this so after something
like rook to F 1 simply rook captures
rook captures rook captures Bishop
captures and this is completely winning
for black as he is up three pawns
so after this beautiful rook to d2 idea
but what an teaming resigned the game so
I think the it's a pretty amazing game
as black was down a piece for the entire
game I mean he did have this huge pawn
chain on the Queen side
but now he finally equalizes he finally
gets back the piece and now White has to
resign because you know the position is
too overwhelming for him so yeah
definitely definitely an interesting
game and I didn't really I was just
interested to see if any of you have
seen this game so I didn't really think
of a title for this game I do invite you
as I mean if you enjoyed this game I
would like to suggest the title so so I
will change the title of the video so
yeah and okay one more interest in fact
I found this to be very disturbing in a
number of ways
after when I searched for for a photo of
mr. Kevin's braggart I googled miss
Kevin's braggart and after you google
canons bracket and click images you get
you get well a large amount of naked
ladies for some reason I don't know what
is this reason maybe mr. Kevin's
braggart did some photography on the
side of chess who knows if you do please
do share in the comments so yeah that's
it I hope you enjoyed the game as like I
said I don't think any channel covered
this game so far thank you all for
watching as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and yeah I'll
see you soon